and so what i'll do in my part of the
presentation i'll start by introducing
the omixlogic program and then i will
pass it on to dr raghav who is going to
be speaking about his
uh
kind of
detailed review of the curriculum and
the types of exercises and projects that
we will conduct
so the omixlogic metagenomics program
is a program designed to introduce the
participants to the role of the microbes
but also to the practical aspects of
data analysis to understand from data
generation to processing to downstream
biological interpretation so what's
important about metagenomics is that
metagenomics is different from many
other types of omics because it is
trying to characterize a community
instead of an individual
so what this program does is it is
organized into several different
sections
we will first cover the logic
why we are trying to ask specific
questions how do we ask specific
questions what are the results that
we're expecting to get then we will talk
about practice how do you practically
try to apply these methods of analysis
and prepare for independence and that
leads us into the project where you can
identify a data set
and plan your analysis and execute it
with the help of technical support
the logic focuses primarily on the
different types of data that
metagenomics covers and the specific
questions that we would be asking using
that data
then the practice leads us into the
specific analytical approaches so that
we understand in detail what are the
types of analyses and what are the
outcomes of those analyses and how do we
know what is significant what is not
significant what is signal and where is
noise
we have to understand that
so in bioinformatics
there's an environment where this kind
of an analysis takes place and that
includes being able to design
sequential
combinations of code which are called
pipelines and so those pipelines provide
us with the outcomes that we can then
try to interpret interpret the
composition of the microbiome in the
environment how does the environmental
or the gut microbiome can be associated
with behavior can we look at the gut
microbiome the skin microbiome can we
identify associations with clinical
factors etc so leading from
the very basic understanding of the
logic
all the way to the application where you
can start analyzing specific data sets
and ask these important questions
the program is organized into several
sessions that are separated by the type
of application the type of project or
the type of analysis that you're going
to be doing
now for those of you that might be
completely new to the area of
metagenomics i want to encourage all of
you to try to complete the free
introduction which is called bytes and
molecules on the portal so sonorica
already introduced you to the portal if
you have an account this is a free
course and you will see there that one
of those is an introduction to
metagenomics so in that course you will
be able to understand the terminology
and the specific types of applications
of metagenomics
what we will do is then later on if you
would like to prepare is you can try to
go through the metagenomics data
analysis course and in that course we
cover data generation types of projects
and data sets and all the way into the
specific analysis and what we will do in
the program is we will actually take a
look at the logic behind the analysis
why these methods were created
how do we apply them what do they
actually produce and we will take a
chance to practice all of these analyses
first of all using our point-and-click
interface called the t-biome platform
a good example that i will demonstrate
here in just a second is the data 2
pipeline so the data 2 pipeline is
divided up into several stages
from pre-processing to then
actual
connecting sort of denoising what's
called denoising data 2 stands for
denoising
and then assignment of taxonomy and
visualization and then we will use this
pipeline to actually understand
different types of visualizations
so let's just briefly take a look
on your portal
on your profile
you will find that with that profile you
should have access to our platform and
this is the link and this platform
combines many of the standard tools that
we typically use for processing and
analysis of data
and if you
follow my example i pasted the link in
the chat you will see that there's a
whole section here dedicated to
metagenomics and that includes three
different sections metagenomics or
microbiome
metagenomics using kind 2 and amplicon
16 has an 18s which looks at
data to and denoising the reeds so that
we can assign taxonomy
so in each one of these sections we have
a demo pipeline and the demo pipeline
actually allows us to understand the
analysis
as we build the pipeline
so going through this interface we're
able to actually see how to connect the
individual methods into a pipeline
and uh
one second
why
this is not loading
okay
let me actually try this again
okay
so after you complete this pipeline you
will also find that there's
visualization that makes it easier to
start looking at the data and
understanding the composition of each
sample comparing the samples in their
proportionate abundance and
understanding the differences between
the different types of
samples that we have using a variety of
statistical and analytical methods so
like here we can see nmds
so in this program and briefly i will uh
just mention several of the important uh
kind of aspects of the microbiome
we will learn about microbiome in the
human body including the skin and the
gut or the stomach
where you will understand the different
types of compositions associated with
different kinds of phenotypes we will
look at how these bacteria form
communities and how we can analyze these
communities to understand the
relationship between
a specific phenotype that we can
interpret in a clinical or a phenotypic
way and the actual composition of the
microbes and finally we will look at
collections of data sets where you can
sample
a specific type of samples
to ask questions
so in conclusion this program is going
to give you the tools
and the logic behind the analysis so
that you can be independent in asking
research questions and conducting the
analysis
getting the results that you can publish
or potentially put into a poster
presentation
so with that i will pass on my screen to
dr raghav